oh the prosciutto
hey guys it's katie and today i'm going
to be doing the tasty 20 minute
challenge and i'm wow it seemed really
sad hold on i'm going to try to recreate
a restaurant quality meal that would
normally take me half a day to prepare
in 20 minutes for my appetizer i'm gonna
be making rosemary fagasha for my main
course i'll be making creamy tuscan
gnocchi and for dessert i'll be making a
chocolate chip ice cream normally this
would take me half a day to make but i'm
going to use some hacks some shortcuts
but it's going to taste delicious
i hope
you really don't want to say this but
start the clock
okay oh my god what do i do first okay
preheating so right now i'm just
preheating my uh air fryer which i
actually have never used this before so
whoo i'm also gonna preheat my oven so
the first thing i need to do is what is
make my
time i start with the appetizers which
is my rosemary faga and i am going to
quickly slice these guys in half and
this is a little hack you put them on
two lids and press them down
and you can slice them all basically at
once like this
okay so this is a rosemary focaccia it's
not really focaccia because i'm using
pizza dough so that's a little trickle
shortcut it's not going to be authentic
but it'll still be yummy and we'll be
adding these tomatoes and some rosemary
let me grab
where's my pizza dough there's my pizza
so with any good fugacio you got to have
lots of olive oil so first i'm going to
put it into this pan we'll add the olive
oil go big with olive oil it helps get
it nice and crispy i can't get it out of
the bag
it's fine i got it okay okay
this is great
all right i'm gonna put this onto my
sheet tray and we're gonna spread it out
into a circle because that's the air
fryer is a circle
and you're gonna press down your fingers
to make these little divots and the
divots are gonna catch the olive oil and
it's
like with pizza dough it's pretty easy
to make it's fast it's filling and it's
delicious i'm also gonna spray this guy
with cooking spray so it doesn't stick
the airfryer is my first hack because
it's going to go a little bit faster
than it would in the normal oven
guys i'm so nervous i need to
i need to zen for a second
okay great i'm going to add in more
olive oil over the top you really just a
lot i like a lot and then i'm going to
put my tomatoes over it that looks like
too many tomatoes too many tomatoes
taking some tomatoes well how much how
much time has it been already okay great
because i was supposed to be farther
than this it's fine okay so now i'm just
breaking up sprigs of rosemary it smells
delicious
calming it smells common and we'll put
this over the top that's what it looks
like all right it's going in oh my gosh
[Music]
setting the timer for 16 minutes so this
is going to cut it tight because that's
a 1658
that's fine next we're going to make the
ricotta gnocchi so normally gnocchi's
made with potatoes you have to boil the
potatoes i'm making it with ricotta
because it's kind of a hack it's a
shortcut and it's they're super pillowy
i originally discovered this kind of
gnocchi because i had all this ricotta
left over from a lasagna there's not a
lot of moisture in this ricotta so i'm
gonna skip squeezing out the moisture
which i would normally do to save me
time i don't think anyone should be
cooking under this type of pressure
i don't have like 15 minutes left
this is i don't feel good
okay so now i need to put three egg
yolks in i underestimated or
overestimated myself
oh
don't break the yolk when you're
separating eggs to get the yolk that's
this is not pretty i gotta go wash my
hands i didn't think this through i
didn't think it through
kelly
this is i have to go wash my hands
it's a place to watch it
don't feel this don't build myself i'm
going i'm going
kelly kelly's nose this is a disaster
okay salt pepper
what if i am nowhere near the time
i don't put pepper in this well there's
pepper in this now i don't normally put
pepper in this but there's gonna be
pepper in this and it's gonna be
delicious i think i think right we're
gonna do
this just be a cup i'm measuring with a
quarter cup this is taking me longer
[Music]
this is the gnocchi i'm making the enoki
so i know it doesn't look like gnocchi
but it's gonna be neogate my station is
a mess what i need is a sous chef
i am feeling the pressure i'm feeling a
lot of pressure oh and i need to add
flour
guys
it's all good i'm just getting my hands
in here because
why not this one usually takes me like
20 minutes and i thought if i i could
condense it down to like 15 to 12
but i don't i don't know that i'm gonna
be able to do that i've got my ball of
dough here
and we're gonna cut this into quarters
i'm going to start rolling this guy out
so now this is the fun part you get to
roll your gnocchi out really fast
really quickly so now we start cutting
them into pieces trying not to get them
to connect to each other how many
minutes do i have
the guests might not be getting dessert
tonight who knows who knows oh the
prosciutto
i'm supposed to have put prosciutto in
the um
the oven so where is that there we go
and we're preheated so that's perfect
timing
[Music]
kelly from culinary just told me to use
a dyke kelly our culinary producer is
backstage uh helping me
[Laughter]
kelly was so much cool and calm and
collected and i am
a mess we are at nine minutes oh my god
i still have to make the sauce and uh in
the sauce the gnocchi will cook i have a
lot to do still but i i could be done
maybe i just gotta kick this sauce up a
notch and make it quick great and then i
am gonna get some oil going in our pan
we'll let that heat up and i'm going to
keep working on these guys as we go okay
i basically
need to cook the gnocchi i need to make
cook up my onions i need to saute them
so that they get translucent and nice
and soft
again these are not how i normally i
like to make them want little and
fluffy like little pillows but they're
kind of chunky boys today just a few
chunky boys i'm going to put my onion in
now okay great
so we just want to get these guys as
close to translucent as possible oh this
is at six minutes i need to cover
with oh it's starting to brown
it doesn't look that pretty
it's fine because it will taste
yummy
i hope
oh i didn't use flaky sea salt on it
guys
it really doesn't look great
it's okay though
because
you just have to keep moving forward a
lot of stuff doesn't always look good
but it tastes good
i will
finish this new game okay
we're going warp speed warp speed
um yeah things have gone wrong for sure
things have definitely gone wrong
kelly stop laughing
kelly's over here like the whole time
she knows like oh she got the salt oh
she forgot the flower like i can feel it
i don't i don't know what happened there
yeah i love you too kelly that's so
scary oh my god four minutes
that's as much gnocci as you're getting
and it's not gonna be even i'm going to
add now the garlic and red pepper flakes
i was just too brave i thought i could
do pasta again okay
yep it takes four minutes to do what i'm
about to do so that's
not gonna make it
i'm not gonna make it but that's okay
i'm gonna just keep a positive attitude
some heavy cream
i am gonna put in sun-dried tomatoes
because you can't have creamy tuscan
without it
oh my god it's france
i am never
this is
a disaster this is how i like i know on
competition shows like i would just
never i would never survive how's the
prosciutto oh god
they're crispy oh god they're crispy
they're burning they're burning
it's good we're good
they don't look too bad they look a
little over
it's fine i'm gonna try i'm trying to
make dessert i'm gonna try this is not
actually ice cream it's an ice cream
um and if i try to make an ice cream
that would take like four hours so i am
going to do it this way
i don't think i was running enough in
the beginning of now that's what i oh my
god i have a minute 47.
great
okay i've never used this one before
it's going well it's going great it's
going great
this is what's going on inside my brain
we'll come back to that
do you have to have a plate in 20
minutes it's about three cups
this is not what it's like in me in the
kitchen
lemon juice
some parmesan cheese 30 seconds
[Applause]
so katie did not finish
um
yeah
this is a nightmare i'm very sorry
internet i'm very sorry to anyone
that watched this i was in here the
whole time in the back
cheering katie on kelly stop laughing
i thought she had it and then
some things happened so i didn't not i
so i failed
that's okay i'm okay i really do think
that my nerves did get me at the
beginning i was so nervous about this i
don't know why i told katie she had to
get that focaccia in the airfare within
two minutes of starting or it was not
gonna cook and when i checked the clock
it took her over four minutes to get in
i'm confused where the tomatoes and
rosemary went on
on the vacation because i saw her put it
on but now it's gone i'm so happy with
my ricotta gnocchi and just like
introducing that to the world if you
haven't tried it i am so excited to be
passing that along
that is really good and then it's a nice
like saltiness from the prosciutto and
the basil is really fresh and for
dessert we have got some nice cream here
which is the banana ice cream
um and i'm very excited to try this it's
more like vanilla than chocolate chip
that's really good and with nice cream
it's not overly sweet i did get kind of
a chunk of
banana in there so it's not even fully
fully
mixed together but overall really really
yummy and just a great way to have a
quick dessert
i think that it's a 25-minute meal
should i say that do you think it's a
cinnamon roll
i think i could have gotten it done
[Laughter]
well that's it let us know in the
comments if you guys want to see me do
this again please please please i want
to have a chance at redemption and keep
a lookout for more episodes and we'll
see you guys real soon bye
oh yes
[Music]
you